pretends to be such a victim black
americans across the country are
actually being terrorized by an
explosion of what brandon talked about
in violent crime just last past weekend
new york city saw
times square bystanders including a
four-year-old shot in crossfire
another tourist was stabbed with a
screwdriver on the subway
now to the south in philly there were
over 20 people shot with four
killed according to the wall street
journal nearly three quarters of
chicago's spike in murders
comes from the city's predominantly
black south side and largely
hispanic west side in new york city
homicides rose 47
last year largely concentrated in
brooklyn neighborhoods with a long
history of violence
as well as the bronx and harlem so
why wouldn't the former first lady or
gayle king spend their discussion
on that reality because they can't
afford to admit that the growing
violence is a result
of months of unchecked blm riots
and the campaign to defund and
demoralize
the police all of which the left
supports
detroit police chief james craig the
longest-serving top cop in the city's
history
is now stepping down but there's an
upside he may be leaving detroit in
order to get to the governor's mansion
one source telling the detroit news that
chief craig is considering a run
against governor whitmer next year and
he joins me now
james craig chief of the detroit police
department who just announced his
retirement
chief a lot of people said uh to hear
you're
retiring you're extremely beloved and
respected in the city but
why did you feel it was the right time
now to step aside
you know laura thanks for having me on
the show it's a bittersweet
44 years i've worked in los
angeles here starting in detroit across
this country been a chief in three
cities
you know i haven't had a bad day but you
know
last year was wake up for me uh
our police officers across this country
are not being supported
and i will tell you the one thing that
detroit police officers will say
they appreciate the fact that leadership
supports them
and unfortunately it's not common it's
not common at all
and so yes i made an honest decision
uh to retire on my own
nobody forced me out uh but i'm being
called into something bigger
i'm not ready to make that decision yet
uh but
you'll know in several weeks
because i'm excited for my next phase of
public service
because public schools chief craig chief
craig
you gotta announce it on your show okay
on this show you mean
you're you're our guy okay you gotta
come here
and make an announcement i tell you what
laura i do this
uh after i retire and i make that
decision
what should i come on your show or
should i come on tucker's show what what
show should i go
come on come on the gap come on the gal
show
at 10 pm eastern time come on
we could go on tucker's show no he's my
buddy um but now we want you to come on
here because
obviously we've been following your
career for so many years
and your message is very important you
said something during your retirement
press conference today i think everyone
watching this show tonight
needs to needs to hear it the aggression
against our police officers today
is unlike anything i've ever witnessed
in my career
but it's not happening it's not just
happening here it's all over we got to
support the men and women
who are out there on the front lines and
when you look at what's happening in
some of these other cities where police
officers
are leaving in large numbers one reason
don't feel supported
where's the country gonna go how are
things gonna
devolve on our streets if this continues
the country needs to wake up these
cities need to wake up
now the portland mayor after a year of
the summer of love
where they continue to riot to this day
right at all last year
now he said enough is enough where's the
support for the men and women
minneapolis
granite we all know what happened uh
with floyd was horrible
but does that reflect the entire
profession and no let's talk about
the tragic incident in columbus ohio
where the teen was shot but she was
armed
and that officer made a decision to
protect another person's life
but yet there are those uh like lebron
a basketball player who says you're next
and nobody stands up and supports the
vast majority
of the good cops it's shameful and i got
to tell you this laura
yeah chief you know me chief you know me
do you think i'm afraid of lebron james
oh please
give me a break uh
i get i got to get my friend out in l.a
when i was out there working with
dion yeah who wrote very spirited letter
has lebron reached out to that los
angeles police officer of course not
and he's not going to we have got to
be because these folks have armed
security some of them are police
officers
and they live in gated communities in
safe environments
but the problem is laura we don't talk
about
those who live in vulnerable communities
who rely on the police
every single well chief we gotta run but
i'm glad you agreed to make the
announcement
on the ingram angle and we look forward
to that announcement
and i i i'm going to fly there don't
don't press me i will fly there
uh chief you guys troy yeah
i'm coming i love i actually love
detroit chief um
thank you and good luck good good luck
for you with your next move but
um you're coming on the show hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else